sí
hola me llamo frank y soy una directora
técnica aquí en pixar animation studios
y te estoy hablando desde el lobby de
uno de los hermosos edificios del campus
pixar como aprendimos en el vídeo pasado
cuando estamos haciendo las tomas para
nuestras películas
necesitamos ensamblar el ambiente donde
se desarrolla la historia si fuera a
construir este tipo de ambiente
empezaría por colocar las formas
realmente grandes como las paredes y el
piso luego colocaría los elementos
dramáticos como esta gigantesca chimenea
que se encuentra detrás de mí después se
enfocaría mi atención en los elementos
de tamaño mediano y realizaría la
selección y colocación de los sofás
mesas y sillas por último me encargaría
de los detalles verdaderamente pequeños
como las revistas sobre la mesa y los
trozos de madera en la chimenea y todos
estos elementos deben de colocarse
usando traslaciones ajustarse a un
tamaño apropiado con un cambio de escala
y orientarse con las rotaciones todas
estas operaciones son ejemplos de
transformaciones geométricas
fundamentales y dedicaremos el resto de
esta lección a examinar las más de cerca
en nuestras películas estas
transformaciones controlan lo que sucede
en el espacio virtual tridimensional lo
que significa que cada punto tiene tres
coordenadas x
y zeta
para esta elección vamos a simplificar
un poco las cosas vamos a diseñar en dos
dimensiones como si estuviéramos viendo
los espacios desde arriba así es que los
puntos necesitan dos coordenadas la
coordenada x indica que tanto hacia la
derecha está un punto y la coordenada jr
indica que tanto hacia arriba está el
punto por ejemplo este punto tiene una
coordenada x igual a 3 y una coordenada
ye igual a 5 antes de empezar a
construir nuestra propia toma de 'toy
story' repasemos cómo graficar puntos en
2d utilizando el próximo ejercicio